if you could get into a top 20
university and you have to get go into a
ton of debt
it is 100 worth it and that if that's
the case
it ain't broken i think it's doing great
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
you know when you're listening to this
it's all going to sound smooth but we've
just recorded this like three times
because remote work
still sucks a little bit um but we have
brie here bree
bree kimmel is an investor in mostly i
think
work work-related products so maybe you
could tell us why it's so hard
uh all right let me just read three
things off your little bio thing here
that i think are interesting so
um solo capitalist so you raised your
own fund
by yourself after never having worked in
vc before that is that correct
that's correct okay great uh another one
according to this you have invested in
seven
unicorns already which is kind of nutty
what are the seven
yeah so started work life about a year
and a half ago
invested in hoppin web flow which was an
angel investment from when i was at
zendesk
um pipe public uh
a bunch of interesting companies and
sort of future workspace
okay wow that's pretty impressive um
okay and then another one that's on here
that i think is kind of interesting
that i think we should just jump in on i
don't know sam where do you want to
start you want to start
with this i want to start with this
bourdain story but that's mine
i want to start with this that's mine
do you know what this podcast is about i
do know what this podcast is about i've
actually listened to many episodes i'm a
big fan
great so we don't need to explain much
to you um so brie um
you and go ahead and plug your new
podcast you have uh coming out
what's it called oh we're coming in hot
we're plugging the podcast already i
thought that was going to come in later
no no we do it now oh and then people
are yes i'm not going to crazy
and they'll do it yeah so we're um
the first podcast after um this one to
be part of the hubspot
podcast network um so myself and my best
friend alexis gay she's a stand-up
comedian
she makes a lot of tech parody videos um
we decided to start a business podcast
with the fine folks over at hubspot who
have been awesome they've given us a
team
we've interviewed interesting people
it's it's been cool for me because you
know as you mentioned i mostly do
software investing and we're actually
interviewing a lot of direct consumer
founders and people that i've never met
before
and so we have this new podcast coming
out called the shake up where we
interview business leaders
about very specific decisions that
they've made that have changed the
trajectory of their company
so hang on is that uh
like is the vibe like comedy because
she's a comedian like is this called her
daddy or is this like
uh you know how i built this or what is
this
it actually that's a really great that's
a really great point uh we're somewhere
between the two
um we wanted to make it interesting and
educational
and it is more of a business audience i
think in this new era
of working from home unless it's
interesting and entertaining
people don't want to listen and so it's
not corporate it's not boring
um one of the most challenging parts of
the podcast for me
is that it's very hard to get business
people off script
they've all gone through comms training
they all have
you know their executive coach to get
them to really open up and share
vulnerable moments or to be really open
and authentic has been surprisingly
really hard
sam is really good at it he uh i don't
know how he does it but he
he breaks through that every single time
um but i gotta
wait sean i mean i i think you're good
at you're you're pretty good at that too
i think we both are
you're good at getting them you're good
at like getting people off the script
really good at getting people off the
script um because sam will do something
like he'll like he'll see you and he'll
be like
he'd be like like yeah he's like you're
good looking i mean like not
traditionally but like you're you're
good looking so
what and then they're like what are you
talking about and it's like kind of a
compliment
kind of an insult and then they're just
trying to figure out like where do i
take this and so then like something
natural comes out or he'll be like
you know ask them about i don't know
something weird that's it that's behind
them in the room or something like that
and uh that usually gets people off so
i'm so so bad at this that i had to
bring
a stand-up comedian to really like warm
up the guests
i i like as an investor it's a little
bit robotic and you tend to ask the same
five to ten questions
and so that's alexis's job she's world
class at getting people
you know maybe flattering them a little
bit maybe flattering herself maybe
complimenting the show but then finding
ways to get people to open up and to be
a little bit less scripted
is it hard to be on a podcast with
somebody who's a professional comedian
like i know sam struggles just dealing
with my level of
my prowess are you intimidated by
your comedian uh co-host you know it has
been fun
um you know now that we have a producer
as well you know the producer is very
clear
at uh helping us define our roles and so
like i know that i'm not funny it's not
my role to be funny on the show it's my
role to like bring in data
and research and i get to be the nerdy
one which is great
um i don't attempt to be funny at all
yeah that's my strategy by the way sean
they have like producers and [__] and
like hey like
they got like resources
the lady who runs the podcast network at
hubspot i'm like wait
brian these folks are getting like
producers and head shots like i've been
using like eric on fiverr
like have to like rig this stuff
together honestly it's i don't even show
up to the meeting so they're probably
like yeah of course you don't get
anything you don't show up to the
[__] meeting why would we give you
any resources
so you've listened to you've listened to
a couple podcasts
i to just so what we're going to do is
we're going to brainstorm a little bit
i know that you who you've got a couple
ideas here that i definitely want to
talk about i want to talk about your
calendar because like when i see that i
just want to kill myself
i can't believe that that's your
calendar i'm embarrassed that you saw it
actually i'm a little bit embarrassed oh
my god
so well i want to talk about a bunch of
stuff but before we
um get into that can i tell you guys
something that's i've been obsessed with
over the past week
so there's this new anthony bourdain
documentary um i actually don't remember
what it's called
um do you guys know what i'm talking
about a roadrunner it's called
roadrunner okay so it came out last week
and it's basically about his last
maybe uh three or four weeks of life or
something like that and it talks about
like details his last four weeks of life
and talks about the his whole journey
and whatever that's not the point the
point is is at the end
they have this amazing sound bite so
basically right before he died he wrote
an email to someone
and it wasn't like a suicide note but it
was like like i'm sad type of thing
and you hear him read that email well
it's not actually him uh it's ai he
never actually
said that but he died you know he wrote
the email and then he died and this
company
used this technology to to read out the
email
and it sounds just like him if i wasn't
like a nerd and researched it i would
have thought that it was him
and i started i started thinking about
this i started thinking about a few
things
and um the reason i kind of putting all
this
together is i read the story about this
guy last week named josh and basically
what happened was his girlfriend
died and he used gpt3 or
gpt3 and he loaded up a ton of social
media messages like you know facebook
messages and tweets and twitter stuff
or and and text stuff that she had said
and he put it to gb3 and he made a
girlfriend who
knew she died and he could talk to her
uh and and
and and like feel like he's still
connected hey
do you think this is wrong and creepy b
that anthony bourdain thing that's
obviously that's gonna happen that
should that's gonna happen
in the future how movies are gonna are
gonna come about but three
when are we gonna start talking to our
dead moms
came in hot at the end there is this
crazy like
like it like the fact that anthony
bourdain did this
isn't it wild that we're gonna be having
these conversations i don't hang around
with the smart enough people to be
to be who built your stuff yeah did you
ever see that episode of black mirror
where they did this basically so do you
watch any black mirror sam
no it's all right it's a little bit
depressing but it's like too accurate
also at the same time so
the in in black mirror they take this to
the extreme and basically this
girl's living with her boyfriend and
then by the you know middle or end of
the episode you realize that this
boyfriend is not like real he's
basically like an ai robot that is
just like kind of like he's not perfect
like so it gives her companionship
because like
it's like he's still here he's doing all
the things it sounds like him and it
looks like him
but he's not actually human so it's kind
of like you know the uncanny valley it
doesn't seem
it's not actually the real thing and so
it's kind of depressing for her
uh to be with this kind of like shadow
of her boyfriend or whatever
and so there's been a bunch of people
trying to do this with gpd3
and um somebody did it with our podcast
i don't know if you saw that uh somebody
uploaded my a bunch of stories i told or
something like that
i put it in i saw that yeah and he's
like look you can ask john a question
and then like it gives a pretty real
like it's like me when i just [__]
some answer it's like it bullshits it
just as good as i can i'm like wow this
is kind of amazing
so i think we're getting we're getting
closer to where that's
that's like um it's like the anthony
bourdain thing where
of course it's not gonna be fully
accurate but damn it's like
it feels like magic it was that this
wasn't really a thing five ten years ago
bri what have you seen in that space
yeah i mean one point i'm at with the
bourdain piece i mean what's interesting
there is
you know he the question is are you
building a legacy
and are you carrying someone's story
forward i think that's really cool i
think if there are sound bites or old
songs or if you can
take a book that was written a decade
ago and then put it in the voice of
someone who's already
passed away that can be really cool i
mean that's really like a strong
storytelling angle and a way to really
continue their legacy
the kind of the gray area for me
is you know for the guy that's created a
fake girlfriend that's
uh using previous text conversations
like i'm a little bit concerned for him
in in the long the long term you know i
think he's maybe
staying in the past as opposed to like
you know going through
therapy or you know spending time with
family and friends and then like getting
back out there again
and so it probably depends on the use
case and some of the scenarios for these
technologies but i agree
i love black mirror i've watched them
all binge watch them all
and uh it's really creepy to see that a
lot of these things are actually proving
to be true
so then i was i was looking around at
what other stuff is like this there's
just
this one called airwriter.app and what
you can do is you can look at the
variety of different dead authors and
dead famous people that they have and
they've uploaded all their personalities
and you can ask ben franklin a question
it's pretty amazing anyway i just wanted
to tell you all about that
i've been obsessing about this so
there's one that i'm going to tell you
guys about
but you uh i almost don't want to tell
you until i lock in my full investment
but i want to invest in this company i
saw it i haven't even had a chance to
talk to them yet
but what they're doing is um they
basically made a a version of deep fake
that you can do for yourself
so you can thank customers personally
for um
for a purchase or for anything that they
did so basically you record yourself
once sitting in a room like i'm here
right and i say oh you know thanks for
leaving that review on itunes for the
podcast yeah or thanks for tweeting out
the podcast
and then what what it does is it
basically takes me in that scenario and
it starts it off with
hey sam uh you know saw your review just
want to say blah blah but i don't have
to
record the hey sam part the hey sam part
the personal touch
gets basically deep faked in the video
and then they can insert any of the
variables so like let's say it's
ecommerce
i could say hey blank name right so i'll
be like hey sam
thank you know thanks for uh thanks for
shopping with us i hope you love the
casper mattress that you just bought
right and it'll make the whole thing
sound pretty seamless and just input
variables
from uh from a database essentially and
just turn it into your voice
so i think that's kind of amazing to add
a quote-unquote personal touch that's
going to be
you know automated it scales sometimes
scalable
uh my uh scout zach found it and he sent
it to me
i'm really excited for that use case i'm
also really excited to see some of the
bloopers like i can't wait to see a
person's face say hey
first name last name right yeah like
how's your day going thanks for being a
customer
right hey [__] thanks
[Laughter]
i find sometimes the automated stuff
i've tried at some of these automated
gifting services before and if the
database isn't
in a perfect form and first name last
name isn't spelled right you end up
looking like an [__] but it can be
pretty funny
so bree i have to ask you a question it
this is going to sound like an insult
which we just told you i'm
apparently known for it he's about to do
the thing this is not an insult this is
not an [__]
um all right so i'm looking at work-life
ventures so this is this
uh firm you started in 2019 before that
you worked at uh
uh i was looking at your linkedin what
was it it starts with the z that's the
big
software um you had a normal
a good job there so like you are a
relatively normal person
but you are investing in like the most
baller companies at the earliest times
how are like the the left-handed
compliment is like
you're not really like a somebody and
yet somehow you already are somebody
how on earth did you pull this off how
did you go from nobody to somebody i
think
we could go even even before zendus
before zendesk you know i worked at a
big tech company i was at expedia
went to a state school grew up in ohio i
mean we can we can cut the data anyway
i'm a very normal person
i live a very normal life like i'm not
your like
venture capitalist that's flying in
private jets and you know doing all
these crazy things
you might be now yeah you might be now i
you said it sounds like you're about to
make a killing
uh well going back to your point thank
you that wasn't insulting that's like
very
clearly uh something you can see from
linkedin is like you know i i
started out as a marketer um started
meeting startups on evenings and
weekends started hosting dinners
um the interesting thing that i don't
think a lot of people
truly realize until you're on the ground
in silicon valley is
you just end up meeting a lot of people
just by proximity
like you walk into a dinner you make one
or two connections you
keep checking in with them you stay in
touch um
and that's how you build your network
and you know everyone there is going
somewhere like you don't move to the
valley
pay crazy insane rent prices uh to not
be like
in the mix and so i found that you know
a lot of the things that i did early on
as an angel i was really intentional
about
like the angel investment and web flow
um
i had organized a go to market workshop
invited webflow so i had like you know a
whole day
with the team which was great i hosted a
couple of no-code dinners just spent as
much time with them as possible
i try to find interesting ways to really
build close relationships with a handful
of companies
i know we talked about you you mentioned
my calendar
and how insane it is i actually don't
take that many meetings and i
i rarely do one-on-one coffees with
people which is really interesting and
kind of a different strategy from
other vcs but i try to find interesting
touch points that
will give me enough of an angle to
invest in
a company that's starting to work so
webflow can i just read your schedule by
the way because nobody's looking at this
so let me just take
let's just take a wednesday okay here's
wednesday just for for people you
you wake up seven a.m morning block what
happens in morning block are you uh i'm
doing that
usually i go to the gym usually i go to
the gym
during combat i rode my peloton but i'm
now back to going to the gym
right okay exactly so we're going up
until uh about 8 30 so from 7 to 8 30
that's like getting ready to go to the
gym go to the gym it says peloton 45 all
right great
now we have morning block two what's
happening morning block two morning
block two i
send emails to portfolio companies and
ask them for ways to help or sometimes
there's proj
specific tangible projects i have to
work on for a specific company
cool so 30 minutes there then uh okay
where are we at so team check-ins we
have a one-on-one with neil great
email processing i love that you're
like an actual machine i'm a little bit
embarrassed right now this is like
you're reading my diary it's like
you put it on the internet yeah i know
just
hearing it out loud makes me sound
insane so thank you okay prep pitch
number one that's 12 15 to 1
then we have pitch number one so you you
do the research before the pitch then
you take the pitch oh yeah that's
interesting usually
i start the call and then they see my
eyes frantically going around the screen
well i'm looking for like a [__] did i
get
who is this what is the deck what is the
name of this company and i'll just be
like
let's just before we talk about your
company just tell me about yourself
while i go look at what company you are
uh all right so you're doing your
research you do your pitch
uh next step so you do immediate
follow-ups you do your second pitch
prep second pitch second pitch follow-up
text
triage what's that like text text
messages yeah
i am horrible at responding to text
messages i will read them
i will think that i responded and then
i'll reply like four days later
and so i actually block time in my
calendar to go through all of the texts
that i'm getting throughout the day
do you actually follow this i do i do
and i will say for
people um that aren't aren't in venture
or aren't doing early early stage
startups
a lot of thing is done over text and
over phone calls it's a highly
inefficient process it's not
like corporate where you know everyone's
on email and everyone's on slack
it's mostly through one-on-one text
so all right we'll just round it off so
we're going email processing part two
then ad hoc strategy what does that mean
ad hoc strategy
is uh so part of the the goal of work
life is we help a lot on go to market
and so typically we're working through
various different go to market
strategies for certain companies
gotcha then you do a virtual dinner
amazing uh
life admin so that's like you know what
laundry what is that code for laundry
uh when i when i published this it was
around the time i was
i had a crazy backlog of just like
random things like i woke up one morning
was like my driver's license is expired
my passport is expired
i haven't left my house in a year like i
need to get my life in order
and so that was the week that they said
this was screenshots and published
there you go all right evening block
from 8 p.m to 11 p.m and then what
bedtime 11 p.m yeah usually okay do you
think that's a difference we want as
well and so i could probably like throw
in my sleep data if we want to get
really weird
do you so i i um i try like i say no to
everything
i think shawn you might be the same way
but for my i try to have nothing on my
calendar i don't want to talk to anyone
ever
uh and like a meeting to me is like a
really big deal like i just don't want
to do it
they gave me an ea and i was like oh so
great first time having an ea what
what do you do and they're like oh like
calendaring i manage your calendar
if you want to book meetings i'll book
them for you if people want to book you
i'll do it
and i was like oh okay all right uh look
you're gonna love me this is the easiest
task ever
somebody asked for a meeting just say
hey he asked if you could slack him
instead
and then if i ask you for a meeting just
say are you sure
and just delete all the group meetings
in the next three weeks just delete them
and i'll add them back in if they were
important
and so basically her job was just to
make sure nothing gets on the calendar
rather than
taking things off rather than putting
these on
do you think that um this calendar has
been this discipline do you think it's
helped you because it's
i mean i'm looking at like i'm trying to
find all the unfair advantages to how
you kind of came up so fast probably not
going to say
it sucks i can tell you i can tell you
pros and cons
pros to the pros to the insane calendar
is
it did provide a lot of structure i felt
that working from home
uh i am not the best at working from
home i will say that and so the
structure has been really helpful
um it's been great the reason for a lot
of the
uh new routines is because i do have a
team now so i have a team of five people
behind the scenes and so i need to make
sure that the the firm
is running accordingly and so i think
having that structure is really helpful
um i also find it does help me say no
and
to have specific moments throughout the
day where i text founders or jump on a
call
just because i i had talked to a lot of
traditional venture capitalists and
if you ask them how they spend their
week or if you ask like you know what
did on friday
friday afternoon like what did you do
this week it would all be a blur because
there's so much activity and so many
things that are happening
and so i found that quantifying it a
little bit was a nice way for me to at
least establish some of these routines
like
will i continue doing this forever
probably not but it's at least something
that was helpful
um when getting the firm off the ground
and
sam we were looking at that that
spreadsheet of uh
what do vcs make i think we should talk
about that so this is one of these yeah
this is what does the solar capitalists
do yeah um so
the reason why go ahead you find it sean
and then i'll talk
so bri bri the one of the reasons why
i'm prodding you so much is
this whole vc world it it kind of um
i i just like i can't tell if i'm just
low iq i just it's really hard for me to
understand
like how the money actually gets in
debris pocket
you know like how i understand you
invest it i understand you um
invest in in startups and you wait 10
years to sell but like
sometimes i'm curious like okay but how
much money can you actually make
and so we recently found i have no idea
how our friend found it
a spreadsheet that i think it's all uh
user submitted salaries and carry
numbers
of maybe like a thousand different vcs
do
you want to read it read that often i'm
trying to find it it's a little bit hard
to find here
while we're while we're live but
basically i don't know if you could do
it sam if you could find it but
basically it broke it down by fun size
so it's like all right if uh
so you were p people were volunteering
their information here's what i make
that's my base compensation here's what
i make as a bonus and here's what my
carry is
and it was like you know my fund is 0 to
50 million 50 million to 100 million
100 to 250 million and then like all the
way up to a 2 billion plus fund
and um and it was it's even there
there's like quite a lot of variety
right because
not every partner has the same deal but
what it looked to me like
was that for small funds um
and you correct me if i'm if i'm wrong
here but this is this was my my summary
of like
you know 500 rows of data just
eyeballing it it looked like
if you work at a small fund let's call
it under 100 million dollars
is your fund size um the good news is
you know you're taking two percent of
let's call it a hundred million that's
two million dollars
and usually it's just one or two
partners maybe you know some
some admin people kind of behind the
scenes um
but you can you can basically take a a
large salary
and you have a large percentage of the
carry but you um
but then on the other side the small the
small funds seem to do pretty well and
then the lar the really large funds
that were like a two billion dollar fund
their
you know their fees itself is insane um
right two percent of two billion
every year that you're taking is a large
number and then they're carry
um you know they're the multiple they're
they're expecting to do on a two billion
dollar fund they may they may not 5x
that fund they may just two exit the
fund or three x that fund
and so their carry expectations are
different it looked to me like this
venture capitalists kind of have like a
high paying job maybe 400 500
000 a year and then if they hit
winners like you seem to have hit some
winners or you have some winners in your
portfolio
like you you you've hit a lot of winners
if those pan out if hop in
truly does end up as a five to ten
billion dollar company
then you know you're gonna you're gonna
have a big windfall which might look
more like
20 to 50 million dollars can come your
way if these winners pan out go public
and whatnot
so tell me how accurate that is or like
put differently what are your
expectations on like how much you can
make doing this thing you're doing now
yeah um great question i wanted to touch
on something that sam
said as well um what's interesting when
you look at venture capital today
is when i was initially starting the
firm
i went into this with a belief that
venture
is or traditional venture is on the
decline i saw angel investors that were
getting into really great rounds
i saw um solo capitalists or super
angels like i know scott belski has been
on the show
elod gil is a close friend and someone
that's deploying
a lot of capital i mean a capital that
looks like almost a large top-tier firm
and so i saw that individuals were doing
the work that you know a 20 to 30 person
venture firm
were doing and so i think it's
interesting to see like i'm a great case
in point where i was in marketing i went
to a state school i grew up in ohio like
i'm by no
means a pedigreed person but i have been
able to build a track record and i have
been able to raise outside money and i
think this is
just like the very very early days for
what's about to happen where there will
be
a lot more people that look like me and
there will be a lot more people that
start their own firms
because i think it's one of these things
where like the nature of venture is
changing
and my investors like smaller funds
because you have one of those
higher return profiles as opposed to
some of the larger
institutions that their multiple is
coming down over time and many of those
lps are having a hard time getting
access to those funds at all
so a guy like um so who what was the
guy's name uh alad gill
is that you say zayn i've read a great
book by him i forget operator's manual i
think it was called no
high growth startups or something like
that
manual handbook uh yeah it was good that
was a great that was a great book
i had i hadn't heard of this guy but
like i see him everywhere
and so is this just basically an
incredibly high net worth liquid person
who just writes massive checks to
hundreds of startups a year is that just
i mean is it as simple as that
um in a lot's case it's a combination of
personal capital
plus outside money as well i will say
that a lot of the solo capitalists i
mean
even the um you know my fund size is
primarily
my first check-in i do a lot of spvs and
i do a lot of follow-on investing and
that's with a handful of lps
and so many of us we kind of publish
here's our core strategy
and then behind the scenes many of us
have other playbooks that we're running
as well
and have you made have you had any
returns so far since
since you've started i have those have
mostly been on the spb front
um you know i i'm setting up uh special
purpose vehicles where i have one or two
lps where they're
um it's it's primarily their capital i
might write a small personal check or
something small out of the fund
alongside that
but i'm starting to see some returns in
companies however i will say
i'm holding on all of those positions
what do you think is a re because this
is what the thing me and sam talk about
which is like
with investing you have you have
illiquidity for a long period of time
right now typically right you
invest in a startup it might take seven
ten years for it to exit
um and along the way you're getting
these paper markups
and so i guess like give us a sense of
if you are if you do go the solo
capitalist route and you i would say
you're like
the success case of going to solar
capitalist route there's a lot of people
who could try it may not have the same
results as you but let's say
things work out how do you think about
um
because i think a lot of people are
trying to decide do i do this do i start
a business do i take a job somewhere or
do i work at a fan company do i
what do i do and so what do you think's
realistic
expectations for if it works this is
what it looks like over like a seven
year period right the first five years
you're just taking kind of your salary
which might be 250 000 might be
a little more a little less um and then
like but you're hoping by year seven or
ten you're able to get
this this type of a personal personal
win out of it which makes your average
over the 10 years look really good
i guess can you walk us through the
numbers because i think for most people
this is just a black box they don't
really understand
they don't really understand how the
money would what the money could look
like in this
uh if things work out yeah
i i'm hearing all sorts of variations to
this model
i mean i have friends who are running
early stage startups and they've raised
you know five to 20 million dollars and
they're deploying capital
while they're operating i think that's
the best case scenario i mean if you're
ready to start a startup
and you have ceo potential and you know
exactly what you want to build
that is going to have a much higher um
you know you're
you're building a legacy there you have
the ability to hire people
like those people will even start
startups like i just think there's so
many great things when ceos are active
angel investors
that's why i chose to raise from a lot
of founders and not traditional lps or
you know traditional finance financial
institutions
um i think they have a lot more access
and they have the ability to
invest in startups opportunistically not
as their full-time thing and while they
still have really great access and mind
share in the ecosystem
you know for individuals like myself
like you know i had
10-ish years of of tech company
experience i don't even want to say
startup experience because i was at a
big company
and then i was at a second more
medium-sized tech company
and those scenarios you know you your
investors are looking for
your ability you know have you already
built a track record do you have an
ability to invest in really great
companies
um and so that's one thing to consider i
actually spent
about two solid years of blogging
tweeting you know really investing and
building my personal brand so i could
gear up to go and raise outside money
so i think you have to build a really
strong case if you want to raise from
outs from outside investors
um the one thing that i will say um you
know angelus and carta have made this
incredibly easy
i think the forcing function and venture
which has caused you know the ability
for anyone to
become a vc or to raise their own fund
is these platforms which basically
connect you with investors they make it
really easy to manage like your back
office and you know
you don't have to deal with lawyers and
all of that stuff right that's the habit
you dodged my question on how much money
you could make but that's okay maybe
maybe you don't want to answer that
no let's go into it i think this is fun
i mean this is this is the the title of
the podcast so i think i think we should
go into it
um i would say so every solo capitalist
does it differently
um some people are purely one person
um they're pocketing all the management
fees
they're taking all the carry um i'm
actually seeing today you know if you're
raising a
5 to 10 to maybe even 25 million fund if
you're doing something on angel list
that's a true solo capitalist fund
um you can actually take 2.5 to 3
management fees
um what i did for mine is i did two
percent management fees
the way that i thought about it because
and
this is a rolling fund it could be a
traditional fund or it could be a
rolling fund so
the rolling fund means that structurally
you're able to
um talk about your fund broadly you're
able to market your fund which
historically
um you know you weren't able to market
your fund when you're actively
fundraising
you know if someone has distribution if
you have a podcast um
you know if you're an active angel
investor and you already have great deal
flow or you're
leaving a high growth startup and you
have a great network rolling funds are
great because you can market it and you
can constantly be bringing in new lps
it's not something where
you go out you raise money you ask a
bunch of people for money you know maybe
a handful of people say yes you do a
first close you go out and ask more
people for money you do a second close
like
that historically has been a really time
consuming process and as a solo
capitalist how you spend your time is
your strategy and so you don't want to
spend
the majority of your week meeting with
investors and you're not meeting with
startups
and so it can be something that really
impacts the business model
and so i think that the rolling fund
works well if you already have
distribution
if you don't have distribution and you
you know want to experiment with raising
outside money
oftentimes the people that are doing
this really well are individuals that
have a valuable network i mean maybe
they're leaving stripe or airbnb or one
of these companies where
they have a very entrepreneurial culture
and the people
you know that used to sit across me at
work are likely likely to go leave and
start a startup and they're going to be
able to raise from top tier funds like
that's one of the strategy as well where
i've seen many of them go out and raise
some outside money or
you know there's a lot of the startups
that have been really successful in the
last generation their alumni
actually have whatsapp groups and
they've created their own syndicates
where you can co-invest alongside the
airbnb mafia
or there's a stripe group or that's
somewhere where i spend a lot of my time
where
i help a lot of the alumni groups build
their first syndicate
and that's been a ton of fun because you
get to meet the whole company and you
get to really
you know understand who are some of the
um
power builders i guess i would call them
um inside the company who are most
likely to leave and start something
so so what would you say the the
potential earning then is for a solo
uh capitalist to go back to sean's
yeah it depends on your goals i mean i'm
seeing solo capitalists that are going
out maybe you start with a 10 to 25
million dollar fund one
for how quickly um the fundraising
climate is moving today
you know in the next 12 months you could
go out and raise you know
40 to 60 million dollar fund too um
the interesting thing is like this isn't
purely a new model
i think what's changed is that the types
of people that are starting funds
do look very different from the last
generation um like i look at
um iden san cut at felicis you know he
was a super angel and then started
felice's ventures
mike maples who's been on the show you
know mike was a super angel and then he
started floodgate
i think what's different today is how
fast you can make money
because there are spvs and ways for
individuals to invest in later stage
companies like early stage is one thing
but i think later stages where a lot of
people are finding
great returns in a short amount of time
so you have your 25 million dollar fund
as the operator what do you expect your
your your pay to be
it's a good question i mean as as you
said earlier i mean a lot of people are
holding for the long term and so i
wouldn't bank on cary
you know in the first you know seven to
ten years
but you do get a a reasonable salary
because many
solo capitalists are do taking 2.5 to 3
management fees so 2.5 2.5 percent of 25
is
is what i don't even know i can't do
math in my head
so that's uh there's a great line on
pomp's podcast you guys somebody asked
them this question they're like wait if
somebody has 100 000 bitcoin and bitcoin
goes to
750 000. how much is that worth he just
goes i don't do public math
think of what they're like what did you
just say he goes i don't do public math
you don't do math in public he's like
yeah i don't do public math and i just
was like that's actually a great policy
i don't do public math so 2.5 of 25 is
so you have you have 625 000 a year in
salary off a 25 million dollar fund
and then the carry a fee sorry and then
if that and if you're solo
so yeah that's a great living and then
what what what would you estimate you
could do with your fun
three exit four exit do you have like a
target
uh right now it's north of five x
damn all right so five x so that's a
hundred uh
four what i can't i don't know 125
million 125 million
you pay back the 25 first so now there's
100 million a profit
of the 120 100 million a profit you keep
20 that's 20 million
so you might make 20 million at the sort
of in
the termination of the fun basically
after 10 years
that sounds amazing right it's amazing
it's amazing i also find i mean
when once you get into this world um
typically you'll see that's that's the
core fund and the core fund is like your
v1 like that's the first thing you do to
build a track record and to like get in
the game
where people start to make a lot of
money and make a lot of money in the
short term is what i mentioned doing
spvs or even buying secondary
one of the things that i've been doing a
lot over the last year
year and a half is one of the things
that holds people back from starting a
startup
is the fact that they're illiquid and
sitting on a lot of equity at their last
startup
and so there are a lot of vcs that are
exploring like what would it mean to
buy shares from you know employees
to then put them in business and so
that's another way to think about it as
well i think there's
different playbooks that you can layer
on top of each other once the fund is in
a good place then you can get more
creative with spvs or you can get more
creative with even
buying employee shares and companies
that still have a lot of upside
um you know and so i think that becomes
pretty creative as well
let's switch gears to ideas so what
spaces what ideas
uh do you have that you think people
should be building in or you
you see interesting stuff so give me a
sense of like it can either be a
specific idea
or it could be kind of like a trend
you're noticing what do you got yeah
it's interesting i tend to look at
what are the smartest people that i know
thinking about or working on
i consistently see um a lot of people
are moving into crypto and into climate
change i think these are two
areas that you can't really ignore um
and i'm also seeing people leave very
well-paying jobs that have a lot of
equity
to work on things like climate change
and so i do think that there are trends
that are starting to bubble up that have
maybe been
either underserved by venture
underfunded rather and so it does
seem like there's a lot of things that
are happening especially
during covet i feel like during the
pandemic
people started re-examining what matters
like you take away the fancy office
you take away all the perks you take
away
the ability to you know physically
see your team and so i'm i'm seeing a
lot of people that are leaving to work
on things that they actually care about
which is really interesting
not to say that they won't make a lot of
money but to say that there are new
opportunities and new types of companies
that people truly want to build and so
that's been something that i've been
thinking about
so what um what's an example of some
yeah i was going to ask about climate
change and
climate tech that's interesting give us
a cool idea in climate change that
you've seen or you have
yeah i mean today it feels like it's
very early days i'm seeing a lot of
companies that are thinking about
carbon offset or they're coming up with
ways for
corporations to be
think more think in more sustainable
ways
i will say i mean a lot of the stuff
that's directly related to climate
change
i probably don't see because i do a lot
of workplace and future of work stuff i
think a lot i think we're going to see
more specialized firms that are focused
on climate change or that are focused on
frontier tech
the cool thing about being a solo
capitalist and having more of a
perspective on like
this is my area of expertise and this is
where i can add value means that when i
get together for dinners with
other new solo capitalists or new funds
they're specialized in their own way and
so i do like spending time with
experts on climate change and frontier
tech like there's so much happening in
space right now
do i have the you know the experience or
the network to really dig in
not at this time but i love hanging out
with people that are working on space
tech
and what uh in in the work life
portfolio so
future of work what's um what's an idea
that
that our company you're excited about
that's not already
like well known it hasn't hasn't had
that breakout moment where
raises a huge round so people in tech
find out or everybody's already using it
like slack or something like that
so what what's an example of a company
that you think is super cool
give us one from your portfolio yeah
absolutely
one thing that's not obvious about the
work life portfolio is i do spend a lot
of time in education
and reskilling i think this is a really
important thing where
even from your earliest days like kids
are brought up
being asked by their parents like what
do you want to be when you grow up
and i think this is sort of a question
that historically
you know kids have been taught to do
very normal jobs
like well you should be a teacher you
should be a doctor you should do
like these very traditional things there
was an interesting
um study that i read when i was just
thinking about work life building out
the first version of the pitch deck
where kids today are you know kids would
rather be youtubers
than they would be astronauts like maybe
that change that changes today because
we're now going to space and so space is
very cool again
but what's interesting there is there
isn't really
education that aligns to that you know i
think the textbook education is you
memorize something you take the task
and you forget about it like my recall
from elementary school middle school
high school is
zero like i studied for a test as soon
as the test was done i didn't think
about that topic again
but i am seeing new platforms and new
styles of learning
that kids are being taught based on the
things they're interested in
i invested in a company called primer
which is essentially
online education i think we're thinking
about like do we call it homeschooling i
think homeschooling tends to have a
fairly
negative or you know neutral connotation
depending on who you are
but the concept is can you know eight to
ten kids get together and can they learn
video game design can they learn about
you know certain types of writing can
they build their own websites like what
are these tangible skills that
are aligned to the hobbies and interests
of kids that they develop at a very
young age and can they
build their own network or community of
other like-minded kids so they actually
care about school
when i bring so i've been thinking about
this whole school thing
both sean and i have invested in a
little bit of it sean teaches a course
i've taught of course before
i've been thinking about school for a
little while and i've actually
completely changed my opinion it was one
thing now it's the total opposite
the whole like i think that the the
everyone talks about education is broken
it's broken
this and that i think only part of it is
the for the top 30 universities i think
are doing
just wonderful stuff and here's why sean
if well you're different i didn't go to
a fancy school
brie if you could have graduated if you
had to graduate with a quarter of a
million dollars in debt
but you could have gone to harvard would
you
i actually think i would to be honest i
think it's worth it i completely agree
it's 100 worth it it's 100 worth it
if you could get into a top 20
university and you have to get go into a
ton of debt
it is 100 worth it and that if that's
the case it ain't broken i think it's
doing great if someone's willing to like
go into a crippling amount of debt and
go ahead
why why okay okay great why do you think
it's worth it because
you learned so much from those great
harvard classes no right that's not the
reason why
you don't learn the school is not about
learning cool so you get the stamp that
says i went to harvard
yeah so now every time a guy like sam or
me looks at you
oh harvard okay yeah you perk up a
little bit um and then the second thing
is
you get the network right so you're
gonna bump into you know
the next winklevoss and zuckerberg and
whoever else
uh that's on on your campus at that
moment right those are the two reasons
the stamp and the network yes the
problem is that there's schools like
belmont university where i went
that costs fifty thousand dollars a year
and then they're like
[__] belmont i mean who's this no one
knows what belmont is they
provide zero value um like there's no
point if you go to belmont you should
quit right now
and basically the only way that we
should solve education i think is by
letting those businesses just go out of
business and die
and then keeping in the top 20s the top
20-ish
i agree with that i mean the liberal
arts schools are hurting a lot i think
the 40
50 60 000 a year school i mean i grew up
in ohio and there's no shortage of like
liberal arts colleges that have a
beautiful campus
but you know is it the type of school
that
someone's going to pull your resume and
put it at the top of the pile or
in the era of today we have ai that's
scanning resumes and they're scanning
specifically for harvard stanford mit
like those are the people that have the
one up and so i do agree with that
yeah that's nice well i think i think
but you're saying you know
you you change your opinion did you
think that before that harvard was a
waste of money
did you really think that yeah i was
like good while hunting like you know
like
yeah like you're going to go you know
for like eight dollars of late fees you
know yadda
yeah i mean you want that romantic crap
to to be true
but it's not my wife went to an ivy
league school i was such a redneck when
she said she went to penn i was like
oh is that where that football rapist
coach went that sucks uh
and then she was like no it's part of
the ivy league i'm like i really don't
know what that means
i think i've heard about that in like a
harry potter book but um
and like then i met her friends and i
was like well this is totally worth it
100 worth it whatever i actually i have
a bit of fomo i i very rarely have fomo
but
going back to my crazy psychotic
calendar
um the virtual dinner on wednesdays is
with friends that are vcs that all went
to stanford gsb together
and so i'm the only non-gs beer on this
virtual dinner we used to meet and have
dinner in person we weren't always
internet friends but what's interesting
there is once you start having dinner
and getting to know them you're like
[__] i could have been
like hanging out with you for two years
all the time like grabbing lunch
hanging out white boarding coming up
with startup ideas like
the whole concept to me makes a ton of
sense because once you start start
spending time with
friends that do have an ivy league
education you just feel a little bit
jealous because they got to hang out a
lot more
when i was at college so i went to duke
which is kind of like more like
more like what you're talking about sam
and uh i remember
after my halfway through my freshman
year or something i called my dad
and i was like hey you know before i
came here we had been thinking like
should i go to a state school i could go
to university of texas
or should i go to duke and like you know
i'm not doing so great here like i kind
of like you know i'm like a
minus student type of thing and i was
like i'm
at first i wasn't trying now i'm trying
but i'm still a b minus student even
after trying because like the kids here
are just like
everyone here is like the smartest kid
from their high school so
like they're all smarter than me and
then they all already work harder than
me i'm just
learning to work hard um and so i told
him i was like you know i feel like if i
stay here
i'm just gonna kind of be like in the
middle of the pack
and i started telling i was like he's
like well why do you um
like you know i i think you're being
hard on yourself and i was like no no
like
my friend tophek is like super genius
and like
during the summers you know i go home
and play nba 2k and he goes and drives
like a
you know an ambulance on the war front
in palestine like helps people
and like my other friend over here he's
doing this other thing and so i was
trying to say that as like
you know i'm not i'm one of them
i think you're wasting a lot of money
sending me here like this i'm not gonna
be a winner here i'm gonna be like
average or below average as far as the
rest of the kids here
and he goes you're not there for grades
you're there because tawfiq is your
friend next to you and that guy's your
friend over there
you being friends with these people
you're not even going to realize it but
your whole
what you think is normal is actually
going to be excellent
because it's just going to seem totally
excellent will seem average to you just
by spending four years with these people
so don't stress yourself out about the
grades don't don't worry about all that
you're doing the right thing just by
being by being like five feet away from
all these other people
and i was like man that was like you
know that's like dad hits you with some
wisdom and i didn't even really realize
it at the time i was just like okay i
guess i'm staying here
uh but now when i look back i'm like wow
that was actually like kind of a stroke
of genius
uh and on his part and
and so to bring it all back whenever i
hear people talk about like the future
of education
education is broken i'm like maybe
like it's broken in the sense of like i
think people shouldn't pay for this
stuff
unless it is of this caliber but also um
i think that a lot of people approaching
this this this market
they think like well i just need to make
like a better mousetrap or like i need
to um
just like make it so you can learn more
important stuff and i'm like i don't
think that's actually the right way to
go about this
the mistake is uh oh man the classic
we're still teaching you know these
classes and they're teaching it from
textbooks how boring i'm gonna teach it
i'm gonna teach better subjects in a
better way and the problem is that
people don't choose to go to college
for the classes they don't choose to go
to college for the information they go
because they want the stamp and they
want the social experience
and then they want you know the parents
need that as an insurance policy
and uh you know so college does many
things and then they solve only the
information problem
but they don't have a credential they
don't have the social experience they
don't have it the other five reasons
that people actually go to these places
that that ends up being a big problem
bree what i'm looking at your portfolio
right now
of all these what do you think is going
to be the biggest hit
right now hoppin's the most obvious um
this is a really
special company um you know when they
initially raised their first round of
funding i believe they had around four
employees um i caught up with johnny
last week and they're
at 800 820
so i invested a little over a year ago
they're now valued at 5.65 b
um and so they're really building a a
really
disruptive platform i say platform
because initially they started out as a
way
for companies and festivals and
publications
to host conferences online they've since
then moved into streaming
they're moving into all forms of virtual
collaboration and even hybrid
collaboration
where hoppin is being used at in-person
events as well
and so i feel like this is a company
that has uncapped upside
they're making a lot of acquisitions um
you know they
have only been around for two years um
you know johnny was initially based
in london he built hoppin because he had
an
illness where he had a compromised
immune system he couldn't go to
networking events
he was you know in his early-ish mid-20s
um and so he built the technology
because he needed it and so
like the team itself is in it for the
right reasons and moving really quickly
and so that's one that i'm super excited
about um
you know but there are a couple of other
ones where
they're stealth they don't have a
website yet they're
building quietly behind the scenes and
i'm very excited for those companies to
come out as well
but you can't talk about those right now
i can't talk about those ones
what are they doing what are they doing
two two
themes that i'm really excited about the
first one is
disrupting venture capital and that's
controversial because i myself am a
venture capitalist but a number of
startups that i've invested in are
non-dilutive ways
for people to raise money like i think
venture
has a very they look for very specific
things typically it's more
it's more um software focused business
models
you know typically it's founders that
are in an ecosystem where there are a
lot of vcs i think that's changing but
it's going to take some time for that to
change
what's interesting to see is i was the
first money an investor in a company
called pipe
um pipe is non-dilutive capital for
software companies
or now any companies with recurring
revenue that wouldn't
that that one's going to make you a
bundle how do you end up as the first
money in pipe how does that happen
yeah i i'm excited to tell you this
story because it's it's it's atypical
um what happened was i was in la for my
birthday
um so my birthday is september 12th i
heard about pipe on
september 10th something like that um i
was at
drinks with friends they're like you got
to meet this guy harry hurst he's very
charismatic he's building something in
sass like you got to meet this guy
and so i had called a few investors i
was emailing people i'm like hey you
know how do i get an intro to harry
wasn't happening wasn't happening and
then finally on my birthday
um i tracked down his phone number i
text him i'm like hey
here's like here's who i am here's what
i do i'm in la and it's my birthday can
i come to your office
and so he um you know we ended up
meeting in the middle he's like okay
uh you don't have to come to our office
we can go to soho house
and so we we caught up on my birthday i
was super excited about what he's
building
um i committed on the spot i you know
started the process to wire the money
from the parking lot like i'm sitting
there on my birthday
late to my own birthday laptop out doing
all the things to get ready to wire
money for this company because i knew if
i waited it wasn't gonna happen
um you know founders are meeting so many
angel investors and so many vcs through
the process
where sometimes i'll talk to founders
and like yeah room are so excited to
work with you
two days later they're like oh i
completely forgot because it's been a
whirlwind
and so i wanted to make sure that that
email was sent that we started the
process and that i was going to keep
bothering harry like frankly we didn't
have a relationship so i was bugging
the [__] out of him so i could invest in
the company but
okay so let's take it even a step
further this even though i've i lived in
silicon valley in san francisco for
eight years and i felt like i was
you and i probably shared so many
friends technically i guess i was kind
of part of it but not really
but it all like this guy harry how did
he even create this much hype
for you to chase him down like that
there were a couple things so
harry um it's a disruptive model
i will say that you know we've seen um
new ways for founders to raise money but
oftentimes
there's misalignment because you'll have
ways for founders to raise money but
it's on unfavorable terms
less sophisticated investors and so for
harry he
the initial concept was enough where
where investors are like oh we need to
catch up with them and like learn what's
going on here
it sounds like you were the first money
in but people were telling you you got
to meet with this guy who are those
people why were they even saying that if
they weren't already investors
in the company what was he you know who
who are these people that were giving
you this great tip
that you were like okay i gotta i gotta
meet this guy and if
if they hadn't already invested because
that makes sense when somebody's
invested they say hey
i just invested in this thing it's great
for you should check it out
um but that wasn't the case here that
wasn't the case there were a lot of
people that were trying
to meet pipe um you know i think a lot
of ways when you're fundraising for a
company i always encourage founders like
many of them get discouraged in the
beginning they're like no one cares like
no one cares until
everyone cares and that's how it always
works like the last
12 hours of fundraising is always a mess
because once people
once someone hears that someone else is
investing or someone else is interested
it just
all snowballs into like a huge amount of
texts and phone calls and emails and so
in harry's case
um he's he's a brilliant fundraiser i
mean if you look at the cap table he's
raised from
the ceo or you know one of the
co-founders of every major sas company
and so i give him a lot of credit for
that
from the earliest days um you know he
had a conversation with david sacks so
you know david had
started yammer and and david was very
interested in it for the same reason
that i was interested
for me as a first money and investor
pipe is a great resource where when a
company hits a certain inflection point
and they're thinking about raising more
money
it's great for me it's great for the
founders it's great for anyone that's
been involved from the very beginning
to introduce options of non-dilutive
financing
um it's more upside for us it's better
for employees like all the way around
i'm like i want to spend time with this
company
and ultimately get work-life companies
to use it when it makes sense
and so that was part of it as well so
then it was basically so did did he know
david um i believe
harry met um someone on david's team
that's la based i just like a cold email
or something something like that
so that that's kind of interesting so
like
i mean it's just like it's a huge game
of telephone and
it's fascinating this is just a
fascinating thing what what is pipe
valued at two or three billion dollars
north of two now yeah okay so they don't
have that much revenue like
everyone it's it's just crazy that you
could say that they're probably gonna
grow into that and become way bigger
but they created all this off of like a
really good story and very strategically
getting in the right years and i think
that's incredibly fascinating and really
really cool
it also just speaks to the amount of
capital that's available in the
ecosystem right now i think oftentimes
these valuations are getting out of hand
because there's so much demand from the
last round
or there is so much
money where investors would rather pay a
high
pay a premium to have exposure to the
company and to share in some of that
upside than waiting until you know a
traditional milestone or metric or
moment in time where historically they
would have fundraised
like to give you context and i don't say
this uh
as someone who wants to brag by any
means but when i invested in pipe it was
at like a nine
post and now they're worth north of two
billion and so that's not saying like
well
you're a world class investor like
you've changed this company
but it's to say that when you have a big
vision you have a good team that's
building it when you have
a founder that's exceptional at
fundraising like investors will come to
you
and they'll come to you even before you
know the next financing round because
they want to get in
so how much you gonna make off that one
i'm holding
it's hard to say i'm i'm holding just
what's your stake worth
uh i don't know if i'm allowed to say
that am i allowed
i'm not sure what the rules are i don't
know if i'm allowed to say that what
size but i invested
i believe i invested um 150
k and then i'm continuing to follow on
well so like
there's a lot of math here that involves
dilution but you just told us the
you just told us the you know the
variables that we could do the math
but we don't do public math if you
recall so we don't do publicly
we could tell you the number but we
don't do public math and we should
you could do like uh all this evaluation
might be like well if it's worth
2 billion and you invested at 10 10
million dollars i mean like
and 125 grand like you know you could do
the math it's it's a whole lot i just
don't know
you know don't don't do it it has on so
on paper it has returned the fund and so
i ha
i have returned the fund in the the
first year and a half
um which is an interesting point i i
think a lot of
investors are very quick to scale the
fund size like they want to go out and
raise 100 million dollar fund for fund
one to raise a little bit north of 10
million
and to return it in the first year and a
half like that's a pretty safe bet
um and one where i didn't overextend
myself in a way where it could impact my
reputation
that's something that i do encourage
people i'm like start with where you are
today
um and find ways to keep building
concentration over time
do spvs buy secondary like do whatever
it takes to like hit that annual number
that you need to make to be happy
don't necessarily overextend yourself
and go out and try to raise 100 million
fund i wouldn't have been able to raise
100 million fund but i i have been able
to return it on paper very quickly
right well congratulations and so uh we
should wrap it up a little bit
over time and we saw her calendar so we
know we're we're eating into like a
peloton class or like a pitch meeting
or or email processing maybe we don't
know exactly which one but
texting triage
all right so we won't we won't keep you
any longer all right so so brian
campbell where should people find you
and they should go
uh let's is the podcast live yet can
they go subscribe
uh on the field yeah subscribe to